right the thought of heading back to
school for some kids and families
it may be daunting so professional
counselor melody parker is joining us to
discuss
back to school anxiety hi melody welcome
to the show
hi thank you for having me all right
today we're going to go through the top
questions that you
get asked in the first one i'm nervous
about going back inside the school
building
how do i reduce my anxieties
so just something for parents to
remember talk to your kids
calmly have a plan in place maybe go
through what a typical routine would
look like
when we prepare the night before laying
out clothes
talking about what the day is going to
look like ahead and then when we wake up
are you going to ride the bus are you
going to eat breakfast do you eat
breakfast at school
just making sure you have all your
supplies needed for the day
and then what the routine will look like
when you come home and just reassuring
them
that they have the support that they
need you kind of give them a driver and
i love it a practice run
so with the numbers increasing how do i
prepare my child
to return to school so covet is
everywhere we hear about it on the news
on social media
and just putting it to them plainly you
know being open and honest
some families you know they have safety
precautions that they put in place
and maybe in their backpacks have some
hand sanitizer
napkins extra masks not napkins but some
tissue
and just be honest if there are things
that you don't know
let them know we don't know and maybe
that can be a family activity of looking
it up
or even talking to their doctor about
now this is one i know you get asked
often
how should i communicate with my child
about how they feel or about their
emotions
so we model our emotions for our kids to
see
and again it's about that transparency
so just allowing them to be themselves
check in don't do too much pressure you
know because you want it to be
a welcoming opportunity for them to come
and talk to you how they feel
and so when you get angry or frustrated
share that with your children letting
them know you know what
mom dad is angry i need some time to
cool off or
you know i really had a frustrating day
today and this is what i did
to let them know everything is not going
to be happy and rainbow and sunshine
and so in those moments when you can't
be happy and just kind of shake it off
this is what i do to ease the negativity
so just being open with them the general
theme i'm getting is just just be honest
with your kids and you have
you have a grounding exercise that
everyone can do what's this exercise
that you have for us
so think about your senses it's five
four three two one
five things that you physically see so
for you what are five things that you
see and you state them out loud
right now three yeah tell me i see devin
i see christian i see the news desk i
see mercedes getting ready for
momsplaining and i see you in front of
me
okay four things that you can feel
physically feel what are four things
that you feel
i feel my my ipad right here i feel my
suit jacket
my pants um i can feel my shoes
and i can feel my right microphone back
back there
okay what are three things that you hear
three things that i hear it's quiet on
the set someone talk i hear devin
telling me we got 30 seconds
i hear vanessa taking pictures and i
hear christian over there he's fiddling
with something so those are the three
things that i hear
all right two things that you can smell
two things i can smell i just did some
oyster shooters so i can smell the
oysters
and i can smell i can smell my hair
product
all right and then one thing that you
can taste i can still taste those
oysters
so that's real easy you're using your
senses five four three two one
five that you see four you feel three
you hear
two you smell and when you taste that is
great stuff thank you so much for
joining us i think this is advice that
everyone can
help me of course yeah we can use in
school or at home
for more information visit mending
broken pieces counseling on facebook
and instagram